foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show but we help you win in your
life specifically your money as it
relates to your money your work and your
relationships that are tied to that
money we want you to win my name is Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
fellow Ramsey personality George
Campbell we're here for you this hour
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
uh there's no easy way to say this our
hearts are heavy
in the Nashville area this morning it's
now national news
another school shooting
lives have been lost I'm not going to
get into the reporting game because I've
if I've learned anything George is that
the details are changing fast
and suffice it to say
another senseless senseless shooting and
life is precious
and life has evil in it and it's hard to
square those two
um my daughter is being picked up right
now by my wife because uh her school
stopped to pray some of the students in
her school knew know some students over
there so again details continually
coming out and unfortunately another
story but this time it's in our backyard
so uh hearts are heavy absolutely yeah
it's it's one thing for this to happen
in the nation another one for it to
happen you know down the street it
becomes extra real and I know you as a
parent it hits differently when you've
got kids in school and this stuff's just
happening and it's sadly oh it's another
week another shooting yeah and it just
breaks our heart so our thoughts and
prayers obviously with everyone affected
and all the parents out there who are
just dealing with this idea of your kid
not being safe in a school yeah in
today's world so God forgive us
but we take your calls today because uh
unfortunately uh life does move on I'm
glad I'm not in the news Ken I'll tell
you that I am too tough gig
um but we're here to help and so here we
go let's go to Rico in Milwaukee
Wisconsin Rico how can we help
hey yeah thanks for taking my call I got
a simple got a simple question
um so I have twin boys they're about
they they just turned 14 and they've
been working for the past two three
years just saving up money shoveling
snow mowing lawns and you know just just
working hustling and they're about to go
into actual Workforce and they've saved
up a pretty good Nest Egg each one of
them they about they had about 2200 each
saved in a savings account awesome so
they watched financial peace with us
because me and my wife are going going
through the university and so they
watched the videos and they're asking
where they where should they invest
their money in because they see the
video or Randy talks about the two
brothers or one investor when he was
younger the other one did later and they
say they want to be the other brother
they want to invest sooner and so they
kind of they both you know want to know
where should they put their money other
than just the savings account they have
that's incredible well you've done an
incredible job as a parent steering them
towards this I assume these guys are
living debt free they want to continue
to live debt free
emergency funds so we just want to know
where where to start saving up I'm like
I'm like I don't have an emergency the
fun but in case you did I guess right
there y'all already set up sure
they want to you know their goal is to
to be you know millionaires at an early
age and I tell them all the time they
will be parents
don't be like your parents are being
dead at 40 years old so like this way
you don't have to worry about it when
you're our age so well here's the thing
mathematically speaking investing right
now is not going to cause them to be a
millionaire anytime soon but that muscle
is what's really important so you could
open up a custodial Roth IRA and they
can put their earned income into that
and you said they're entering the
workforce these kids are 14. tell me
about what Workforce looks like at 14.
um where we live and they actually could
work like at the uh you know the Piggly
Wiggly or or like the local uh
restaurants here that can like work as a
work work there so it's not like nothing
too strenuous but they can actually
start actually have an actual job are
they in school as well full-time
yeah they do full-time school and then
like during the winter time every day
shovel snow around the neighborhood and
then summertime they cut lawns around
the neighborhood so that's how they kind
of make their money I love it so in a
high yield savings account is a great
place to park all that money and I
personally if it was my kid or I was the
kid I would not invest into the stock
market right now and here's why they've
got a lot of Life coming at them in the
next four to six years when you think
about buying a car going to college we
just there's so many variables we don't
know and I don't want that money tied up
in the stock market because they want it
to be millionaires they're going to be
millionaires as soon as they figure out
what's next and they start investing at
21 years old up through 50 they're going
to be multi-millionaires but right now
there's just a lot of variables at play
and I'd be cautious about going all in
on investing
all right well thank you for the call
Rico and and why the caution well
because at 14 years old you're about to
get your driver's permit you're excited
and so what happens when you have all
your money in the stock market you go I
gotta get a car loan I don't have any
money yeah you save up for proms that's
what I'm facing this week
um I forgot about prom it's like you got
to save up for just fun life things is
the idea right or you know I want them
to still be kids and so while it's great
to invest a little bit of money it's
easy to turn that dial too far and at 14
you've got you don't have a dollar to
your name because you're busy investing
yeah I love that what sharp kids I love
it Jackson is up next in Tampa Florida
Jackson how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking the call I'm
basically wondering if my wife and I are
in a position financially to go ahead
and pull the trigger on a second vehicle
uh we currently have one and an electric
bike okay we got about two minutes so
give George the numbers pretty quick
uh net worth is about eight hundred
thousand uh bring home about 150 uh
annually and
uh basically I'm wondering if it's okay
to jump into a nicer vehicle I'm
thinking like a Toyota Tacoma for maybe
thirty thousand dollars or so or if I
should purchase something a little more
hoopy and then upgrade that what's your
other card at a certain time it's a
Honda Odyssey we got a family of five
what's that worth
uh
uh yeah 16 000 Maybe so what's wrong
with paying 30 000 cash for a Tacoma
uh well I would have to pull it out of a
brokerage fund
um but I don't know if there is anything
wrong with it that's why I'm asking if
you've got the cash and you're not going
to debt as long as all of these toys
things with motors in them don't add up
to more than half of your income which
you just said you're pulling 150.
yeah and so that would be 75 is your
upper limit for that and it sounds like
you're not even close to that
okay yeah so even with uh even if I have
to pull it out of brokerage it wouldn't
yeah yeah that's not retirement funds
that's just a taxable brokerage account
yeah yeah what were you investing for in
that brokerage account
uh it's just yeah I mean for funds s p
you know what's fun having a Tacoma you
paid cash for yeah I would do it yeah
definitely no hoopty but you know if
you're feeling like I don't want to
spend 30 then what can you get what kind
of truck can you get for 20. you know I
mean you got options is what we're
hearing I mean you guys are debt free
with an emergency fund
yes yep dude get the Tacoma yeah this is
what this plan is all about you got
freedom you got options you're doing it
without debt you're not setting
yourselves back financially and this is
what investing is for so you can enjoy
your life now and later and you're doing
it man proud of you yeah go get your one
I love a Tacoma do you like that if I
was gonna get if I was a truck guy it'd
be a Tacoma yeah really you know I love
a Toyota account you do you do I think I
would get an American mate just me
because I'm a patron America I want that
thing to run till I run easy easy all
right hey we're not going anywhere your
calls coming up next this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
the Ramsay show continues I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel with a K
by the way it's Coleman and camel today
what are we covering that sounds like a
law firm that I would not hire I know it
really does yeah like bad suits you know
like one of those like injury lawyer
commercials double lapel yeah there's an
actual camel in the commercial that's
what you now we're talking yeah uh we're
here to answer your money questions of
course but I'm here I'm the work
personality and so for decades Davis
said that your income is your greatest
wealth building tool and I specialize in
helping people make money because George
they're doing something they're good at
and they love and we saw in our
millionaire study the largest
millionaire study of all time that 96 of
millionaires loved their work and that's
what I do so it plays into the money so
I'll take your work questions you're
feeling stuck you got a really crappy
leader you're in a toxic environment you
feel stuck not a ladder to grow I'm here
to help so that you're making more money
and moving through the baby steps faster
so the bigger shovel guy can we say that
I like that I need a shovel when I host
the show I'll just bring it here like a
big snow shovel that's aggressive is it
a little aggressive kind of lead it up
again maybe you want a little a tiny
tool you know just for digging some
mulch that's great well tiny tiny shovel
for a tiny co-host that's perfect that's
wonderful oh that's terrible I like to
see you as the purpose guy thank you
because people their craving purpose and
it's a luxury in today's world we didn't
have 100 years ago that's the truth we
went from survival to now we want to
thrive that's right and you help them do
that that's right and the money thing
works with that so let's go Lori is in
Cookeville Tennessee not too far away
from us Lori how can we help
uh yes I just wondering how we can not
continue to lose money so we can stay
retired oh okay walk us through this how
old are you guys
um I will next month be 62 my husband
the month after will be 61. okay and are
you both working are you both fully
retired no no we've been we've been
fully retired since we 54 and 55. wow
and I will yes yes
have you been bringing any income at all
no no no so you're just pulling from
your nest egg
well when we first started for the first
year we had some
um yes but just from our nest egg from
investing what was the total Nest Egg
when you retired and what is it today
now we've lost like 300 000 in the last
few years okay yeah you said we keep
losing money what did you mean by that
our investments
going down what are they currently
allocated in
uh
stop mutual fund
funds and annuities but that's all part
of the
um total okay I know you're working with
a financial advisor right now yeah yes
absolutely and we are have an
appointment to see what
one that was recommended by Dave Ramsey
um on April 6 to see what his plan is
yeah my guess is one of our smartvestor
Pros which is our financial advisors we
recommend across the country they
probably wouldn't have put you in an
annuity
now most of them are are Just Junk
there's only one very specific scenario
that would make sense for that but as
far as you losing money what is a
percentage that you've lost because
everyone has lost money 23. okay 23
that's about right I mean the S P 500
lost to 18 in 2023 and so everyone
across the board has seen about a 20 25
dip in their retirement accounts which
hurts okay so we're not I mean I know
other people have lost money but yeah
okay well that's not outrageous Yeah
it's unoutrageous you're not alone and
then remember we're telling other people
who are not in retirement age who aren't
drawing from it just hang on you know
it's a roller coaster don't get off the
ride that's when you really get hurt in
your situation the question that I've
got uh is what what is your fixed uh
budget do you have a fixed budget you
guys are really disciplined with and
what are you essentially drawing
absolutely what are you drawing in order
a year
um 65 000 we are completely debt free
and been for years we only have one
vehicle
um so you're drawing 65 000 from the
retirement account about six and a half
percent a year what is your Social
Security
mine will be eight hundred and twelve
dollars and that will be basically our
cost of living raise for you know
everything that's gone up that's right
you're not even you haven't even started
drawing that yet correct not till June
my my first tech comes in June well my
husband's the following year which will
be fourteen hundred dollars okay
so that's good perspective to have my
parents in a very similar situation you
know they're they're they have no debt
and they they can truly live off of
Social Security and so their retirement
is just great yeah and you guys have no
debt I assume
none love it okay I'm gonna throw
something out here Georgia and I I I
just think that retirement
is overrated and what I mean by that is
I said this on my show today I said all
the time you know I I think we're
created to work and and I think that you
can slow down yes have a lot of freedom
yes but I wonder in a situation like
this where they go you know what what
could we do for 15 20 30 hours a week
they get to choose they don't have to go
to work but if there's something that
they enjoy doing that can actually make
some money I like that I like going back
to work at your pace at your choice Lori
I really do to offset some of this well
well we you know we live from we live
far away from family for a long time and
we have a camper we bought for nine
thousand dollars so we camp a lot near
family with friends and the things we
enjoy doing is just building things and
you know hiking so we don't just sit and
we're healthy yeah but my point is if
you like building things maybe I'd make
a little money on the side building
things and Ken's point is to alleviate
some of the stress because the key when
the market is down is you want to take
out as little as possible yes because
what you're dealing with here is
something called the sequence of returns
risk what that means is if you take the
same chunk out this year while the
Market's down it's going to hurt your
ability to grow that money that would
have grown in the future with compound
interest and so you it'll shorten your
time span to live off that million if
you take the same amount and so what you
want to do is be as conservative as
possible while the markets are down like
this so only take out what you need if
you don't need all 65 000 take out forty
thousand and that will help this money
uh to to live longer as you live longer
and so that's what Ken's saying if you
can bring in 20 grand this year from
part-time work that you love yeah that
allows you to take out 40 Grand from
retirement instead of 60. so
I guess our other our question is should
we be more in mutual funds do we have
too many stocks and mutual funds because
I would stick to mutual funds personally
which are highly allocated towards you
know equities and stocks and So within
that yes but I would not be investing in
any single stocks at your stage of the
game okay or for any one stage of the
game I just I don't do any single stocks
personally I don't do any crypto I'm all
mutual funds index funds giant piles of
stocks with the top companies that's
what you're looking for yeah
okay and our smartvester pros and we
want you to interview two or three of
them okay and and you want to find the
one where you've got a good connection
with it uh with them you want them to be
able to explain things where you
understand so you are making decisions
not them but they're going to walk you
through our investment strategy I think
you guys are going to be in good shape
and and again I don't want to beat a
dead horse here George but I I gave them
I gave Lori the advice I'd give my mom
and dad
and that is in fact my dad I'll give you
an example so my dad's actually doing
this he's a retired Pastor never made a
lot of money
uh they paid their house off probably 20
some years ago my mom and dad's
household expenses is really low okay
it's less than a thousand bucks okay
and Social Security more than covers
them but he's out filling pulpits
getting paid 500 bucks a week you know
just preaching and it's not a lot but I
mean that's more than enough for them
and so he's staying active and he was
just telling me on the phone the other
day uh I love it my mind is fresh uh
he's still engaged and the science shows
that that actually allows you to live
longer yeah listen if you want to die
quicker
I got two words for you stop working and
you'll go downhill faster so there you
go you get to choose but there really is
something I mean I'm not joking around
there really is the data here on this so
I think retirement's overrated slow down
well I think the idea here is have a
plan Beyond I'm gonna stop working yeah
I like financial planning for your
future freedom in your future long term
but not working I don't like that
neither does your body don't move more
of the Ranger show coming up
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George camel we're here for you the
shower triple eight eight two five five
two two five taking your money questions
and then your work related questions
that may be affecting your money I'll be
here to help out on those by the way if
you're new
to the program whether you're listening
or watching George and I want to say a
big welcome secondly you're hearing
jargon baby steps and and and and advice
and philosophy and you're trying to
figure out how does this all work we've
got a wonderful tool for you to get
started into this conversation see where
you are
on this journey to having Financial
Peace by going to ramseysolutions.com
and click on get started it's the get
started button at ramseysolutions.com
just take a few minutes and we'll get
you started and plugged in
to the resources that fit you for your
journey triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number Anna is on
the line in Asheville North Carolina
Anna how can we help
hi
um so my question is more honestly for
my children but it is relate to me thank
you for your honesty
I Wanna Know
how or are we saving enough money right
now for our children for a more secure
financial future when they become adults
how much are you saving right
so
um comfortably we're able to put away
between two to four hundred dollars
between the two children
um
we again are we're not completely debt
free my husband and I are working
towards that we'll be fine it's just
that I don't want our children to be in
the same position by the time they reach
our age currently how old are the kids
set up
there are only two and three this is
what I want to start now or is that
silly oh it makes you up it makes you a
really amazing Mama Bear you know
there's no shame in that now George has
got a process that we teach here that
I'm sure he wants to dive into but I I
love her heart yeah you're you're
thinking the right way and I love that
you want better for your kids and you
don't want them to experience any
Financial pain like you guys have but
the truth is just like on an airplane
they tell you to put your mask on first
and that's what I want you guys to do
for yourselves is put yourselves in a
better financial position by getting out
of debt and having a fully funded
emergency fund and investing for your
own retirement before worrying about the
kids
the kids got time on their side
they're two years old and so you just
don't want to get to the place where
they're you know now 18 years old and
now we're just thinking about putting
something you know like I said we're
we're okay
um I want you to be better than okay
right okay and I want you just be okay
for the next 16 years and we don't know
what the future holds what if your kids
don't go to college there is a 100
chance Anna needs to retire one day
there is a 50 50 chance the kids go to
college and graduate yeah that may be
changing even as we speak and the data's
showing that that's even getting skewed
yeah so how much debt do you guys have
so
um mortgage is 330
um cars between the two cars is 35
000 credit cards is 18
000.
um and then between my husband and I
student loan 40 000.
okay what's your household income
uh right now
145. awesome what do you guys do
so I'm a health advisor and my husband's
a network engineer and again we're both
stable no fear of losing our jobs
honestly we just got busy or independent
like both of us so you know I really
don't and foresee any any troubles in
the near future and we do have some
questions saved up for our monthly bills
we're at like three months okay right
now
um again it's just these beds or like
the the car payment the car loans and
stuff are something that we've accrued
honestly in the last two years just
because we bought a minivan because now
we have two children
um you know things like that so it's
it's not what's the what's the interest
rate on those credit cards
uh we have one that's 5.99 I think
there's one that is the Amazon one is
the 17 but that's only 2 000. okay yeah
let me lay this out for you Anna to make
it real it'll be much more digestible
for you so we're going to ignore the
mortgage right now you guys have a
thousand dollars in the bank anything
outside of that let's start throwing at
this debt you have 93 000 in Consumer
Debt you guys make 145 based on some
napkin math how quickly could you pay
off 93 making 145 if you were super
focused
very quick two years or less
yeah two years I was gonna say we can we
can do it okay um so think about this
future though you now have a
four-year-old but you have no debt and
you're working towards that fully funded
emergency fund you still have 14 years
to help them cash flow college but
here's the difference you don't have any
payments anymore so how much more could
we invest
two years from now
hundreds if not a thousand dollars right
kills honestly it makes so much sense
it's just that I yeah I guess that is I
didn't want to wait any longer yeah
you're doing it from a beautiful place
you have a wonderful motivation to help
your children My worry is that they have
to help you because Mom and Dad didn't
prepare prepare for retirement because
they were busy helping us go to college
debt free
and so we're talking two two and a half
years from now you're in a different
place Anna and I'm I'm so proud for
where you guys are going I know those
kids are gonna go to college debt free
if they choose to go at all yeah Anna so
the answer to your first question is no
you're not you're gonna stop that in
fact whatever you've put aside you're
gonna pull all of that and you're gonna
start attacking this debt with our debt
snowball the smallest debt first knock
that out take the minimum payment on
that that you've been paying or whatever
and you're just rolling it rolling it
rolling it and George we've got let's
get let's uh have you guys taken
financial peace or have you read Total
Money Makeover are you just listening or
watching the program what's your what's
your exposure to us
honestly I just saw a couple videos on
YouTube today and I saw the phone number
so I called and I wrote down baby steps
by Dave Ramsey I was thinking of buying
the book so I can read it well you don't
have to buy them today because you're
the greatest Mom that uh is on the
planet we're gonna give it to you so
George what are we giving her Financial
Peace University I think Financial Peace
University yeah 100 let's get her in a
community of people that are walking
through the same Journey you'll find
that uh Community is huge when you start
a journey like this because here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna run into
some people who try to talk you out of
this stuff because it makes just too
much sense your words to George moments
ago it just makes so much sense but
because
it's making so much sense you'll find
that this world is full of Uncommon
Sense and very little common sense so
that's why people are like oh it just
makes too much sense George what's wrong
with the picture I love that it's so
simple because then like even a dummy
like me can understand it
you're no dummy I appreciate that I'm
excited I'm gonna thank you so much
you're so welcome so hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up we'll get you
that but can I want to do some math for
Anna real quick on the college savings
side well so she's worried there's not
going to be enough love it break it down
but we just told her two years from now
she's gonna be debt free that's right
the kid's four years old which means you
still have 14 years until they turn 18.
yeah if you just invest 400 a month
that's 4 800 a year tracking with me I'm
still with you for 14 years with the
average rate of return of 10 uh-huh
which is what we've seen with the S P
500 it's actually been closer to 11 11
and a half I like what you're doing
you're being conservative here's how
much you'll have 14 years later 135
000 now tell me if the kids work in a
part-time job has got some scholarships
and you have 135 bucks a thousand
dollars can these kids go to college
debt free if they choose the right
college and the right major yeah maybe
stay in state and what yes what if your
kid doesn't want to be a lawyer doctor
and by that time I'm predicting that
higher education is going to be largely
irrelevant oh the next decade of higher
ed is going to see a lot how they're
going to have a lot of money to get
trained whatever that means to do what
they really want to do so you win in the
end regardless of college or not College
you're going to use that money uh that
you've invested in their future training
and education very wisely so that gives
me a lot of Hope but the problem is Ken
we're trying to do 17 things at once
yeah we never get out of debt we never
have a fully funded emergency fund we're
trying to invest for retirement throw a
little for the kids college and 20 years
later we're exhausted we're exhausted
well before that goodness that's why
we're wasting so much money at uh Friday
happy hour drinking our faces off wow I
didn't get the invite Ken well because
you and I don't do that you and I no we
play Spades with our own lives and have
popcorn we're playing Cricket yeah what
really quickish I just felt like a Ken
Coleman sport that's more your speed
I'll tell you what's my speed more calls
from real people who want to win how
about that my friend you ready for that
quick commercial break he's George
Campbell I'm Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you joined the
conversation here about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships as they all come
together for you to live the life that
you desire to live I'm Ken Coleman
joined by George Campbell this is the
Ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five and uh George uh it's that
time of year again I I'm going to recuse
myself from this because I say the word
tax and I start deceive and I start to
think bad thoughts and and then I don't
want to say anything bad have you filed
your taxes yet oh yeah I file them as
soon as possible me too to get them over
because it Looms in my life and I like
to get it over with I don't like
thinking about the government taking my
hard-earned money don't get Ken started
no but we do get a lot of questions
about taxes and it's confusing and so to
help you get a better handle on them
let's unpack one of these questions from
our listeners are there penalties for
filing a tax extension well here's the
deal there is no penalty for filing tax
extension it gives you six extra months
to submit your tax return as long as you
file your extension by tax day but
here's the deal even if you file an
extension and you owe taxes you still
have to pay your taxes by the deadline
on tax day if you don't you will get hit
with late fees and penalties so avoid
that so here's how that works Ken when
you request an extension you've got to
estimate your total taxes owed and
compare that to how much you paid in
federal taxes during the year to see if
you have a tax bill but look if you're
going through all that hassle you might
as well just go ahead and file your tax
return you've done half the work already
why not it's figuring out what they owe
what you owe and you can file your taxes
or file an extension through tax
software like our very own Ramsey smart
tax so if you want to do that go to
ramseysolutions.com
smarttax it's easy to use there's
upfront pricing no hidden fees like the
other guys and it's only 24.95 right now
to file your federal return again
ramseysolutions.com smart tax uh if
you're watching on YouTube or television
wherever this might be look at the face
you got there on that little lower third
yeah they've been using money we'll be
happy to talk about taxes I guess they
thought how do we get more people to
file their taxes George's face look at
that face I mean it's a face only a
mother could love I'll tell you that
much well I love the Oshkosh denim
jacket that looks fantastic thank you
yeah that's uh well played well played
what do you shop these days can the AARP
store I didn't know they had there it is
folks we're wide awake now we're moving
we really do love each other but it
takes us a few segments to get snarky
and now we're ready we're like the old
guys on Sesame Street up in the balcony
just commiserating well that's the
Muppets George thanks for playing same
thing all right back to the show
Courtney is in Chicago Illinois Courtney
rescue us safe how can we help you
hello
um I have a question my question is I
just filed my taxes we couldn't have
planned that any better George did you
set this call up no all right
happenstance Courtney you just filed
your taxes how you feeling yes
um I'm not feeling too great I owe the
IRS about 6 500
and that's about the exact amount I have
in my savings right now so I'm trying to
figure out how I should pay that off
okay well the good news is we don't owe
this money quite yet we've got a little
bit of time right
right until tax day are you getting any
paychecks from now until then
yes I am okay what will that amount be
do you have any idea
um I get around like 1900 per check
every two weeks okay after taxes so
we'll have two more paychecks until
through tax day
yes great so can we use that money and
still get by on April 18th 5500 comes
out and you still have a thousand bucks
to your name and some money in checking
yes well I have a separate account for
that a thousand dollars because I was
reading uh one of the books and my mom
told me about uh the show so I actually
have a thousand dollars in a completely
separate account oh great I haven't
touched and then you have 5500 in
another account
yes
that's perfect so we're gonna go ahead
and just use that money and it stinks
because you worked hard to get that 5500
didn't you
yes but think about it this way you owed
that money it would have come out of
your paycheck if we had our withholdings
correct and so it's just it was just
some you know math that wasn't finagled
quite right
so don't get down on yourself exactly
just a gesture withholdings if you want
to avoid the giant tax bill next year
and you can do that with your W-4 form
through your employer no I I want to add
something here George because this is
this type of thing has happened to me
before years and years ago
and I even though I had it set aside and
I was able to make it happen and you
just walked her through the options
Courtney I got to tell you I'm the type
of person I hear somebody listen I go
all right what can I sell how can I make
some extra money how do I avoid dipping
in how do I avoid getting that's right
dipping into my current accounts if I
can offset it even 500 bucks a thousand
bucks 2000 bucks Courtney I I just want
to at least challenge you to consider
well can you sell how can you make some
extra money between now and tax day so
that you're not taking as big a hit
that's what I would be thinking right
okay you know and then just cutting
expenses hey what can we cut in the next
few weeks that's coming up maybe a
subscription a thing we were going to do
our grocery bills let's shop what's on
sale let's eat the leftovers hey we have
a neighborhood yard sale coming up
Courtney and my neighbor if you want to
make the drive down to Franklin and uh
you can set up a little table the gas
money she would spend driving from
Chicago to Nashville wouldn't be where I
didn't think about that but I'm trying
to be kind of native here George I would
go to your yard sale well I wouldn't let
you in there because you'd be
criticizing all my prices you'd be
walking with people going that's
overpressed I got a George camel hack
here that'll save you five bucks or so
I'm gonna wear a fake mustache and show
up to your yard sale Ken as opposed to
hack beard yeah well it's not really I
could I could do better okay all right I
like to see that uh let's go to Leo now
uh wow we're staying in the windy city
area Chicago's popular today let's go to
Leo Leo how can we help
yeah thank you for taking my call
gentlemen um I actually had a question
in regards to a um I have a major home
repair that I have to do for the house
um and I'm just looking to see how do I
go about that if I take out a loan do I
what's the repair what's the repair and
how much is it going to cost
sure it's uh it's the repair is going to
be for our septic tank
and yeah those are a little bit priceier
I'm getting quoted around 20 to 30 000.
um for the first two or three that I've
called
um I do have two more estimates coming
up
um and uh we're on baby step two we're
expecting me and my wife were expecting
our first child in a month and a half
um so we do have around 6 000 saved up
so far but do we take out a loan I I
have no idea how urgent is this
um well it is quite urgent uh because
the work the more we put it off the more
damage we could do to the home and with
the sub pump and everything in the
basement
um so right now for example you know
without getting into too much detail but
the toilets won't even flush uh that
well oh well you handle that way better
than I would have I'd have been like
it's a four alarm emergency can't flush
the toilets
yeah so I have a system right now set up
that's kind of a Band-Aid but it's not
really
um have you asked these companies if
there's a temporary fix that can get you
by for six months yeah I actually spent
around close to three thousand dollars
already for um a discovery for them to
dig it up and uh jet the pipes and all
that and nothing helps oh boy so without
they have to actually just really uh
replace it
and you said this has to happen soon are
we talking a month from now two months
from now six months from now
uh or like next week the toilets won't
flush George I'm gonna go with tomorrow
yeah yesterday honestly but uh yeah uh
what money do you guys have access to
that is not debt
um said you have six thousand savings
yep anything you can sell savings
um I mean we do have
uh we have two hoopties and uh my wife's
car is really nice but all three of
those are paid off I mean I could let
one of those go but do you need three
cars right now
oh I'll use one for door dashing um on
the side as a side hustle and I keep my
they're both very not
um valued cars I probably only get about
a thousand for either of them and then
how about Healthcare what are we looking
for as far as the the bill for the baby
yeah we have great health care through
my job
um so we'll be okay as far as
um I feel like we'll be okay so right
now with our bills and everything we're
able to save the close to 3 000 a month
I'm probably selling mama's nice car in
order to get this thing taken care of
and we'll get her another nice car later
but right now we got two emergencies we
got a baby on the way and a septic to
replace and so we're gonna have to get
real drastic real drastic yeah wow tough
situation
a tough stuff thank you for the call Leo
and uh George good hour I want to say
thanks to James crew keeping us on the
air and to you America thank you for
listening this is your show this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
deeper dive on your money Journey we
have a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships all of those
are tied together we want you having
true peace so you can live the life that
you were meant to live I've been calling
I've joined by my college George
Campbell the shower both of us are
Ramsey personalities and we're here to
take you through your calls Triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
George is our money expert I'll help you
out on any work related issues that may
be holding you back uh your income is
your greatest wealth building tool I
want to help you get that bigger shovel
to get out of debt and get through the
baby steps faster so we'll take those
calls as well but first uh George the
internets are a flame wow uh let me say
that differently uh YouTube
uh all the social media form everybody's
freaking out about the latest round of
negative news I'm not freaked out I know
you aren't but we'll tell people why
okay so the The Source here and we want
to just give a brief amount of
perspective
because the news exists to freak us out
scare us they want Pearl clutching hand
ringing it makes for good ratings George
and then they can sell those ads for a
little bit more money
so the latest is freaking people out
about our financial future specifically
the dollar all right so you've got you
know Putin uh Vladimir uh Vladimir Putin
Mr Russia over there and you got Xi
Jinping who is the Chinese premiere and
now they're hanging out three-day Summit
they're in cahoots George I don't like
it I don't like it either and so you got
Putin and jijing hanging out and they're
talking about an alliance to threaten
the U.S dollar and you want the direct
quote from Putin on this anytime we can
hear from Putin I like to hear from you
I'm tempted to try my Russian accent but
I think I will offend all people groups
in doing so well if you die very
seriously this evening we will know why
okay I so badly want to do it I'm so
nice let's do it it's an entertainment
favor of using the Chinese Yuan for
settlements between Russia and the
countries of Asia Africa and Latin
America what do you he's watched too
many James Bond movies but I will apply
it again that's pretty good so there's
the quote he's saying uh basically they
want to switch from the dominant dollar
oh sure and move to the Chinese Yuan
yeah so which could hurt America
obviously so you've got two schools of
thought when you see news like this
right you can go out on the internet and
you can see a a whole line of Articles
and a opinion saying this is really
scary they're going to collude they're
going to knock the dollar out and
they're going to take all of our savings
is this going to be an absolute disaster
and then on the other side you got just
as many experts and economists and
people going you know what if that were
to happen it would take a very very long
time China can't do it they won't do it
because they own most of our debt which
that part is true so the point we're
making here is we're not taking a
position on one way the other and we're
certainly not going to predict doomsday
okay what we are going to say is
you can control certain things and you
not having debt let's start there George
is a good thing oh absolutely so let's
talk about the consequences if this ever
were to happen which by the way we've
got an MSN piece here saying Plans by
Russia and China to challenge the Dollar
on the world stage are going nowhere
experts say Russia's fragile economy and
China's capital controls make both of
their currencies less appealing if that
gives you any peace right now let's talk
about some of the consequences if the US
were to lose its World Reserve currency
status so firstly the value of the
dollar would likely decrease which leads
to higher inflation nobody wants that
and even higher interest rates right now
here's the interesting part if you get
out of debt and you no longer need to
borrow money interest rates don't affect
you as much do they right so that's why
you're saying get out of debt yeah and I
do want to point out though George
because this is real if the dollar
uh were to be devalued because it was no
longer the reserve currency your dollars
would become pennies now that is a real
now again whether or not this happens or
not but it's not just the interest rates
available it's the value of your money
would decrease it's now 38 to get a
gallon of milk that's a scary scenario
that's exactly that's real terms right
there where everything well you think
inflation is high now okay so you know
this is a tenuous idea what could happen
could really freak you out oh absolutely
so again back to the way we teach in our
lifestyle right so if you've learned to
control your expenses uh you know but
this is by the way George you got to be
careful here I got to bring this up this
is the kind of stuff that Doom prep
Doomsday Preppers they really jump on
they're like you gotta have 400 cans of
green beans you gotta and you gotta
invest go invest in silver and gold all
day long but here's what I tell you that
advice I'm glad you brought that up the
silver and gold are tied to the dollar
so you don't it's not like you just skip
the whole all of the dollar crashes I
got a bunch of gold in their Hills you
know that doesn't work it's tied to the
dollar and so
um this is the type of thing where
there's just there's only so much you
can control and you not having any debt
you're not relying on the federal
government to bail you out it's a good
position to take oh absolutely and uh
the The Washington Post article goes on
to say America's politicians have gotten
used to spending seemingly without any
concerns about deficits and that is
another piece of this puzzle is
America's Got to get on the debt
snowball they really do smallest to
largest let's go now you know what I'm
glad you bring this up because this is
by the way this is both sides of the
aisle here I want to be an equal
opportunity offender what can the
average person do about the potential
devalue of the dollar
I don't mean to be cliche but it's only
take care of your house no no you vote
you vote men and women in there who will
get you know what I'm gonna run on
eliminate the national debt
I mean forget the rest of politics has
anyone ever even attempted let's just
imagine for a second if the American
people a huge of the American people
said all right they're going to run on
one issue alone forget about all the
other issues that are important to you
boy I just offended a bunch of people I
just said what if
what if we had a Congress that said
we're up there to actually kill the debt
we're going to pay the debt down and
America is going to be debt free for
some of you who think this is a
Preposterous idea many states in this
country haven't have a constitutional
amendment where they must balance their
budget
so it is doable there are state
governments in the United States right
now by law they must balance their
budget George which means
they don't have debt they got to balance
it it can be done I like this plan a lot
Ken and if you're running you've got I'm
not but I will tell you there's one guy
I know that if we stuck him in a room
full of people for 30 days I promise you
Dave could get a budget together
Dave Ramsey could put a budget together
that would balance the budget I'm here
for that I think America's cheering you
on right now no no I mean he's not
running but what if we took Dave up
there we made everybody get in the room
they couldn't leave until they agreed to
the budget he came up with I would I
would turn on C-Span to watch that could
you see Dave going to DC James with this
quickie budget form all right America
we're going to do the quickie budget
here and then we're going to work
through this in 90 days we're using
every dollar we're gonna get the federal
budget balance I don't that's an insane
asylum for Dave to have to be in that
room with those people for 30 days I
don't know if he'd survive yeah he would
because no one else could talk he'd love
it he would just tell him how it's going
to be give Dave the mic only his mic so
awesome he's got scissors he's got the
chain he's got everything is all his
props here's what we're doing we're not
leaving until we balance the budget so
we can pay off the federal debt it's the
world's greatest debt snowball I love it
well hey I'm sleeping easy at night I'm
not freaked out about this you shouldn't
be either focus on what you can control
which is your life your money your house
it's that simple that's a good word he's
George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your life your money
your work and your relationships this is
the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined by my colleague George Campbell
today and we are here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
eight eight two five five two two five I
do want to mention that uh the weather's
getting warmer spring is in the air and
we love when people come to the studios
and we've got a great group of people
out in the lobby today of Ramsey
Solutions watching the show looking at
us like we're zoo animals and so it's we
had some students on spring break George
I mean it's it's always fun so come see
us if you're in the national area we'd
love to see you it's a good time all
right let's go to Baltimore Maryland
Chichi is there I know it's chai chi in
my heart is it what
yes
it's GT I apologize for George he uh
he's not Hooked on Phonics let's just
put it that way Chichi I love the cool
name how can we help
okay so I am very thankful to even be
getting any of your time I really
appreciate it wow you're awesome
my current situation is that I just
basically got out of homelessness I'm
living with my parents
um now and I go to school part-time and
I work full-time
um within the field I'm trying to
graduate from uh I have about five
thousand dollars in Consumer Debt my
credit card
um that just piled up honestly when I
was like living at my car but now like
I've been getting my first checks and
I'm I just got current so technically I
feel like I'm on baby steps like 0.5
because I have half of the savings for
baby step one
um but my issue is just should I get
another job on top of this like I don't
I don't mind honestly working that much
it's more so just
um
like is that a viable option yes like
when it comes to taxes because I've done
that before and okay yeah here's one
because you're because you're willing
that's all I needed to hear once
somebody like you says I'm willing to do
it I think you do it because you have
just overcome tremendous amount of
challenges it feels like you're in a
safe and stable situation with your
parents
um and I like working that second job
because you're going to get through baby
step one so much faster and then you
start tackling the debt and you only
have five thousand is that what I'm
understanding that's the mat that's all
you've got
no I have 35 in um student loans okay
but even so even at that even 35
000 uh on top of the five so forty
thousand you can pay that off before you
know it and you talk about a rebound in
your life and momentum and
accomplishment and I think working hard
and not having any time left for just
about anything other than sleep I think
it's the best thing for you right now I
really do I would absolutely do it what
are you going to school for
I'm going to go for information systems
um I switched from psychology because I
kind of realized like I like working
with um special needs kids and these
accessories they have aren't as you know
uh Savvy as I would have thought so my
attempt is just to get into
um a program or some kind of like
Foundation that's aimed at creating apps
for special needs okay are you cash
flowing this uh so you're living with
Mom and Dad are you cash flowing the
school or is this part of the student
loan debt we're dealing with that's
that's honestly what I'm doing for
school cash flowing it it's my end state
college so it's about four thousand for
three classes which to be honest is
pretty good so I was just gonna cash
flow it pay it off during the summer and
the same thing for each semester I have
I'm a junior technically in Psychology
so when I transferred from my older
College I'm like 27 and I left College
in like when I was like
22. so I transferred and they pretty
much said I'm about 70 done so I have
about a year and a half awesome what are
you doing for the full-time job and what
do you make doing it
I'm a help desk analyst I like a local
um gym and pretty much 40 but that's
before taxes after taxes it's like 30.
so 40K at the full-time job
yeah awesome well here's another option
too you can look into is there a
full-time job where you can stick to 40
hours a week but you could make 50.
doing very similar work that's another
option but for now go get that side job
while you're looking for that new
full-time job uh because you know I want
this to be sustainable for you so you
can always scale back but if you can
even get out of this credit card debt
and cut up that card and close the
account you're going to be in a
different place financially nope
that credit card is is not a crutch
they're not your friend it's only going
to compound the problems right listen
Chichi your parents have opened up their
home to you and in this season of
getting stable there's just no reason
for a credit card there's just not not
when you got their support system am I
understanding that correctly I mean
they're totally supporting so you don't
need their credit card people in your
situation think that the credit card is
the fallback it's this emotional safety
net but that's why 25 interest that's
right that's why we want you to get that
baby step one one thousand dollars in
the bank account as a true emergency
fund plus you got mom and dad you got a
safe haven you just don't need that
credit card and with very little living
expenses you're going to find some
traction real quick as soon as you get
this other job
okay I definitely will find something
you're incredible we're really proud of
you I love that you got your head up
high uh shoulders back and you have
decided to move on and I'm telling you
George I've seen it time and time again
it doesn't always have to be money
related but when someone can come out of
a season of uh let's just call it a
storm
and make progress whether that be again
physically mentally spiritually
certainly financially in this case
it is such a momentum Builder to go from
I was here and now I'm here and there's
that sense of accomplishment and working
until you can't work anymore and you're
falling into bed and all you're doing is
either studying for your future
learning for your future and working for
the now so that the next is what you
want to be I mean that's a good
prescription for somebody who was
homeless oh yeah activity baby activity
that's showing me results day in and day
out
there's a certain sense of belief and
and then the confidence follows the
belief it's like okay I believe I can
get there and as I see myself making
progress there the identity changes
haven't you seen that yeah well and what
Chichi just did was move from victim to
Victor and she could easily have been
like well after what I've been through
Ken I've got no she got up and she's
fighting every single day to do work
that matters get the education she needs
get the support she needs work as much
as she needs to provide for herself and
that level of belief where you have an
agency we call it locus of control yeah
you have a sense of agency over your
life that I actually do control things
yeah life doesn't have to just keep
happening to me yeah and what she did is
incredible I don't know how anyone
listening has an excuse after listening
to her inspirational story yeah and you
know we were talking about this and you
deal with this a lot people feel like
that credit card is the emergency fund
but I just don't see any data and I
don't you have either that that that
flies in the face of the conventional
wisdom we've given for decades which is
the one thousand dollar emergency fund
it's gonna cover most emergencies yeah
it's the ankle biters and for the rest
we'll deal with those as they come but
traditionally what happens is you end up
using the credit card as a crutch and at
25 interest now as the interest rate is
that the average right now we're seeing
20 to 25 APR
and it's crushing people because people
I mean just doing the math on that hurts
your brain to go five thousand dollars
at 25 interest and it keeps climbing
every month because you make the minimum
payment yeah these people are not your
friends they're snakes yeah and you play
with snakes you get bit and so the best
way to do it is to just remove that
option from your life and go if I don't
have the money I've got to figure it out
we got to get creative we got to sell
some stuff we got to go to work yeah and
there's just such a sense of
accomplishment even when you're working
hard we've seen it many times on this
show with the debt-free screamers just
working insane hours something you just
didn't think prior to a journey like
this this gazelle intention we talk
about you didn't think it was possible
but when you have a deep why man it
changes everything you're willing to do
it it really does hey I'm so excited
about your future Chichi thank you for
sharing just a little bit of your story
with us you are tremendously Brave you
are on the way up the best is yet to be
thank you so much for calling into the
show all right we got to do a couple
quick commercials we'll be right back
don't move this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
to have you with us I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined by George Campbell we're here for
you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
today's question brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with something interesting when
something in your home breaks neighborly
is the name to remember and with the
neighborly Done Right promise you know
you'll get great service from their
network of local home service providers
go to neighborly.com today today's
question comes from Tony in Colorado my
wife and I recently started Financial
Peace and really enjoyed it and it
inspired us as a result I started
working overtime at my job so we can
hammer out our debt we originally agreed
I would work four shifts of overtime
which is about 30 extra hours per week
but after just two weeks I feel guilty
for leaving my children I've got two
girls two and seven I'm leaving them so
often and leaving my wife to care for
them all day every day even at this pace
it'll be 13 to 16 months before we're
out of debt should I cut back on my
overtime a shift or two to be more
present as a father for my children and
more present as a husband for my wife or
should we both stay the course attacking
our debt until it's gone forever
hmm all right I'm going to answer this
how I would answer it and George you can
weigh in I I I would stay with it I
would stay the course I might
alter it from time to time meaning I'd
commit to it uh for as long as possible
and then if there's one week in a given
month where I'm gonna pull back a little
bit just to kind of soothe my heart
because the here's the deal the two and
the seven year old
while obviously missing their dad
they're so young that it's not having a
negative effect on them right now so
that's why I'd stay the course but if
you get to the point where your heart is
hurting and I've been there where you
want to see your kids maybe a couple of
nights in a week you dial back so you're
not still doing the 30 hours I believe
it was yeah per week maybe I dial back
to 25 one week all so that I can spend a
little time with them that gets my heart
kind of full again then I get back at it
I just think it's the Rhythm that he's
got to listen to his heart and determine
the Rhythm that way well just based on
how he's phrased this he said I feel
guilty so what it tells me is reality
may be different I agree have a
conversation have a conversation with
your wife and say hey how are we doing I
want to check in I know this is a lot
and she may go oh
all good here right and it may just be
in his head now if she says this is a
lot it's crushing me I need you here
more let's dial it back now here's the
numbers on baby step two which is where
you guys are at getting rid of this debt
the average time it takes people to get
out of all Consumer Debt is 18 to 24
months
currently you are on track to do it in
13 to 16 months and so if you dial that
thing back and it takes you 18 months 20
months 22 months you're still on track
now if you said hey it's going to take
me four years to do this if I cut back
I'd say no we got to keep going this is
a big pile but based on your numbers
that's reasonable let's scale it back
but also don't let the guilt cause you
to make a decision let it be from a real
conversation that's right good advice
there and thank you again for the
question all right back to the phones we
go triple eight eight two five five two
two five taking your money questions of
course and I'm here today to give you
some perspective on work if that's
somehow gumming up the whole process or
just making it hard on you life is too
short to work in a place that diminishes
you
and deplete you so if I can help on that
I bet you we can find you some more
money in the process all right back to
the phones we go Dolores joins us now in
Orlando Florida Dolores how can we help
hello thanks for taking my call
um I had a question about
um my mortgage and also I'm trying to
figure out how to
um allocate the money that I have left
over after doubling up on my mortgage so
I've already uh I have a my uh fully
funded savings I already
um I don't have any debt
um so really I'm just at the point now
of trying to pay more for my mortgage so
once I paid double I'm actually at a
little over that point as you say I
think it's 25 of the monthly uh amounts
of your income and so I'm trying to I'd
like to do some updates to my uh home
but it's very difficult for me to
justify taking the extra money I have
and not putting it towards the mortgage
and actually putting it towards me of
doing the home or doing anything to it
so I was just curious what your uh just
just basically an opinion you know does
it make sense to hold off on doing any
kind of updates or anything like that to
the home now or just pay off everything
or
um am I just being stingy with myself so
what are these updates
um updates nothing nothing huge just
things I want to do to make my home more
comfortable
um you know things like you know fixing
you know windows screen doors uh
this simple things nothing that has to
be done okay what would it cost to get
all this done
um I'm guessing probably if I at this
point probably about thirty thousand but
like I said it doesn't all need to be
done and quite frankly it's yeah it's
nothing that's nothing so we can chip
away at this over time
yes okay if I'm in your shoes here's
what I'm doing I'm gonna set a goal in
both areas I'm going to set a goal to
pay off a certain amount extra on the
mortgage and I'm going to set a goal to
save up enough to do some of these
repairs every year
and so if you have both of those you
won't feel like you're out of control in
either area so what's left on the
mortgage
uh sixty six thousand dollars and what's
your income
um before taxes for gross is a hundred
thousand awesome
okay and right now you're making double
mortgage payments
yes okay so if we kept the double
mortgage payments how many years would
it take to pay off the house
um it'll be five years that's awesome
and how how long would it take with the
extra money then to do all these
Renovations and updates
that'll probably take a little bit more
than five years considering all the
things I want to do I mean just paying
for screen door to a patio is like ten
thousand dollars so that that will take
a little longer okay so you could even
dial back the mortgage and say hey I'm
gonna pay it off in six years but I'm
gonna get these Renovations done in the
next three
see when you're when you're through baby
step three we we say you're moving from
intense to intentional and so I love
that you I had a big goal of paying off
the house early so I attacked it as if
it was Consumer Debt because my wife and
I just wanted it that badly but if
you're saying hey I really would love to
be a little more comfortable I've worked
hard there's nothing wrong with slowing
down that home process the key is we pay
it off early we retire with no mortgage
that's the goal
and you're gonna get there so we're just
arguing over you know a year or two at
this point
I hope that helps but it's a tough one
Ken when people get to that stage
there's so much guilt because you want
to see the mortgage gone but you also
got to live your life and the windows
need to be replaced I agree with you on
that I loved how you broke that down I
mean you don't want this ultimate goal
to end up you know for the future to end
up hurting you in the present and you're
still making Headway but you got to live
but I remember that like any outside
expense when we were paying off debt
years ago Stacy and I mean it irritated
me to no end yeah it was like I wanted
to suspend life and go whoa whoa whoa
can you come at me life after I get
through this yes and that's just how it
goes so I like to split the difference I
think there's a it feels like you're not
out of control on either side if you
just go we're gonna allocate five or ten
Grand a year towards home renovations
that's simple right yeah we're going to
throw a thousand bucks a month into a
savings account for home repair that's
12 Grand a year yeah the rest is going
towards the mortgage yeah and set a goal
in that area yeah do you have a home
repair do you do that uh I pay a guy so
we have the home repair fund that goes
to pay a handyman when and if we need
one yes right I know you don't do it see
you thought I was see that's why I'm a
fan of our friends and neighborly
because I'm like I'm not I'm not doing
the DIY game oh no I've been to Lowe's
it's very stressful some people love it
now I gotta tell you this is a tree I
enjoy a jaunt up and down the aisles of
Lowe's or Home I'm just picturing you
jaunting up and down I do I do enjoy it
now uh meaning I enjoy the purchase
process and kind of but I don't I don't
enjoy doing anything I love the smell of
lumber as much as the next guy can but
to try to find an employee to find the
three inch screw that I need that I saw
on the website I mean they don't know
what's going on they're just walking
around going I thought it was in this
section look at the signs on the aisle
then you go and you look up and down at
all the screws it's a 5k to get through
the those aisles can the place is giant
all right little eggs I don't mind it
but I do you and I both are challenged
we're handyman challenged that's for
sure I like to support local businesses
yeah you know what see it keeps the
economy going that's all we're doing it
absolutely and you know what uh by the
way this is why the whole envelope
system which is now every dollar you
know that's why it works you go and you
go oh I'm crying out loud gotta pay the
handyman I gotta fix a window and with
inflation these days who knows how much
a new window costs it's pricey Ken yikes
all right thank God for can we just say
thank God for all the handyman and handy
women out there and women out there that
help us out and the diy-ers who go I'm
gonna do this myself no I don't have any
love towards them at all it's all
jealousy all jealousy and Green With
Envy green within me because I can't fix
anything I can barely put gas in my car
and that I need the YouTube video but
hey I digress we can't help you out with
your calls though that I promise don't
move this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman and I'm joined by George camel
we are thrilled that you are here with
us the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and uh well if you've been paying
attention at all to social media or the
news you've probably heard the phrase
quiet quitting have you heard this
George oh yeah it's all over yeah
there's a new one now too a bare minimum
Monday there it is I know you'd know
yeah it's all about just I'm gonna do
just the least amount possible to get a
paycheck and it's it's kind of pathetic
it comes from the anti-work movement it
does George all work is unethical we
shouldn't have to do this that's what
employers are scum yes the government
please take care of us and boy that
never ends up well it's exhausting but I
digress so here's the thing why what if
you could actually do work that you
looked forward to because you were good
at it you enjoyed it and it created
results that you cared about
that's what I would call the dream job
it's not this no far away thing you know
high in the sky no it's actually I just
spend most of my day using what I do
best to do what I enjoy to create
results that matter to me I call those
three elements Talent passion and
Mission and it's the part it's the the
key indicators that we give you in the
get clear career assessment this is
assessment we created about 15 18
minutes and you're going to get a
detailed report on what you do best
think talent and then what do I love to
do this is work I'm passionate about and
then what motivates me what gets me out
of bed on a Monday morning that's what
the assessment does for you puts it all
into a purpose statement along with your
detailed report so you can begin to see
what your professional future could look
like where you're making a lot of money
and experiencing a lot of meaning you
can get it right now at
ramseysolutions.com
get clear that's ramsesolutions.com
get clear that's the get clear
assessment so check it out all right the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
Candice who joins us now in Huntsville
Alabama Candace how can we help
24 and halfway through baby step two in
my question was
um should I would it be a bad or a good
idea for me to pay for my mom's life
insurance
and why are you wanting to do that
um she just kind of lives there really
volatile lifestyle and I'm just kind of
worried like if something does happen
like she has a lot of death
and just she won't get it for herself I
mean she's borrowing money from her
children half the time so
from you
yeah
why are you letting her continue to
borrow money if you don't think she
manages it well
here recently she always says it back
and I just But Here recently I have set
that boundary and it's no longer
happening
so why why is life insurance The Next
Step
um I honestly just a lot of stuff
happened recently like
um like this
just in her life and I was just
wondering if
like she kind of needs it so I'm like I
guess I just want to be protected I
guess who's reliant on her income
um no one I guess
so she doesn't need insurance the point
of life insurance is to replace income
so a spouse or a child that's really I
didn't know if it was oh sorry I just
didn't know if it would cover like or if
her debts would be our responsibility no
they won't be unless you co-signed on
them so no one's co-signed right
no no okay so this would all get paid
out of her estate
if and when she passes but it's not
going to get passed on to you the
creditors can't come after you and say
well you're on the hook you didn't take
out the debt oh perfect okay I just
didn't know because like I guess
um her beneficiaries are my sister and I
so I just sit and I was worried that's
good glad you called but you listen she
took out the debt and that would die
with her so you don't have to sweat that
now as a beneficiaries you would just
get nothing or less right if she owes a
ton on her estate and it gets taken out
of her you know retirement accounts to
pay it but you're not on the hook for
this she doesn't have any of that yeah
that's the thing so you're not really
the beneficiary of anything now she can
get life insurance but I don't think
she's going to do it and you would need
her consent to do it and you would need
to be an insurable interest according to
the insurance company and is she in good
health
so she might have a hard time getting
life insurance
yeah we got a few quotes and it was
anywhere from 100 to 300 a month okay
due to her age and just a little
lifestyle and if she wants to get a
small policy to cover her final expenses
funeral things like that that's fine but
it you've got to have a conversation
with her uh it's gonna be hard to do it
we have and that's kind of the whole
reason I ask is because I'm like
I'm like bad with money
I feel like she would take out the life
insurance and then like just stop in
like seven or like four to five months
or a month I just don't think life
insurance is going to change her
behavior at all and that's the root of
this issue
right right that's true I would help her
get on her own financially I would set
up a boundary and say Mom we can't let
you continue to borrow money
we want to support you in any way we can
but it's not going to be financially
we can't do that right yeah and so
that's a hard conversation because she's
probably gonna have a hissy fit
yeah she's been using you guys as the
bank
I mean she did recently yeah I mean
that's that was the response I just
can't I'd say Mom I love you too much to
let this hinder our relationship and
letting family borrow money like this is
one of the best ways to destroy it but
let me tell you something Candace I I
would expect hope it doesn't happen but
even though you said there's some clear
boundaries now I would expect that she's
going to come back again and you need to
be prepared for that
oh absolutely
and she's probably gonna throw a tantrum
and make threats and say you're not
getting it's fine I love you I love this
relationship with you but it's not worth
it if I've got these weird Financial
strings attached yeah yeah that's tough
stuff that's really tough setting those
boundaries up getting parents to manage
their money well yeah
uh let's go to Alyssa now in Sacramento
California Alyssa how can we help
hi there um my name yeah you know my
name is Alyssa thanks for having me on
the show just wanted to ask you a
question regarding my husband and I we
just found out that we're eight weeks
pregnant with our first child
yes unexpected but it's a joyful
blessing I wanted to see if we're can
still our goal was to purchase a house
wanted to see if we could still do that
while preparing for a baby financially
as well as living on one income
potentially okay so where are you guys
at financially do you have any debt
what about down payment
down payment I have 500.
500. basically we put it
500 because we put it on hold while my
husband finishes student teaching where
he's teaching full-time for free to get
his credential which she should have at
the end of June okay so what is the goal
for down payment and house purchase
so our goal was to take because we think
that we could do fine with a three
months emergency fund because we never
use it we have we plan to build it up
six months which we did then basically
um to get through this period without
using your emergency fund which we've
done by living frugally and then take
three months of our emergency fund and
make it actually into a down payment
added to the down payment fund and just
have a three-month emergency fund and
then that would give us eight thousand
dollars now you're in California I
assume this house is going to be very
expensive
so if we had I don't know if you guys I
hear sometimes you guys allow people to
do like five to ten percent down on
their first house
um so 20 per 20 000 would be five
percent down and so if we're doing if
I'm doing like side jobs or something
what's your household income with that
one income
um with the one income it's probably
gonna be 55 grand a year this is a
nightmare looking for a place to happen
Okay how much is this mortgage gonna be
um well we were thinking of getting a
duplex where we could that was our goal
before the baby you're going to be a
landlord with a newborn with your
neighbor next door knocking when the
HVAC goes out
yeah I think I think we're trying to
justify the home purchase in California
and the numbers just don't make sense so
here's what I'll tell you I would focus
on continuing to save the down payment
let's have the baby let's see where
we're at financially the five to ten
percent is accurate but it needs to be a
quarter of your take-home pay or less on
a 15-year fixed
and I'm guessing that changes the
numbers drastically
okay so where now all right we need to
find a condo in California
that's way more affordable with more
down payment just to make this work and
renting is not a bad thing to do
especially in this season of your life
with a little one coming in you guys
this is a fun New Chapter let's adjust
to that as George said keep saving you
guys are not going backwards by renting
just be smart patients wow grasshopper
yes good hour George it's always fun to
be with you my friend I want to thank
James and our crew behind the glass that
keep us going I want to thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five I'm Kim Koma
joined by George camel George is our
money expert this hour and I'll be
helping you out with work related issues
so you can make more money move up the
ladder or get out of a toxic environment
or start that company that side business
that maybe turns into that dream job one
day so we'll take all of those questions
and more triple eight eight two five
five two two five Alejandro is joining
us now in Las Vegas how can we help
hey how's it going guys good how are you
doing
good thank you what's going on so um
yeah so I have a question regarding
about buying a house so the situation
that I'm on right now is that right now
I currently live in Las Vegas and it's
just getting
more and more expensive on renting and
the thing is me and my brother haven't
always been so close on financial things
about saving money together and
investing money
um the thing is he he offered me to buy
a house with him so instead of him uh
sir instead of me renting a keeping
renting apartment here in Vegas he
offered me buying a house with him and I
will be paying the house with um the
mortgage for him at the same time the
situation everyone is that I live with
my girlfriend and
um I don't I asked her uh what she
thinks about living with my brother
because it would be financially better
because
um you know he he's really
he's really nice about you know uh their
payments together but
I don't know how to talk to her more
into it about buying a house and it's
it's not my what was her reaction when
you first uh threw it at her
uh she wasn't really happy about it
because that makes her think that um
We're not gonna be really
um together
and it's a horrible it's a horrible idea
relationally I'll let George weigh in on
this this is a new trend I'm seeing a
lot of George with people sharing
mortgages and trying to cut costs and on
paper you know it seems to make a lot of
sense but just relationally Alejandro
you need to listen to her this is an
awful idea I mean positively Dreadful
and I'm going to speak as the guy who's
been married a long time uh
happy wife happy life and and this is
this is like uh this is this is
foundational like marriage 101.
um this is just a dreadful idea I can't
think of a more awkward situation that I
could put myself in than buying a house
with my brother and having my girlfriend
move in and who's paying who and who
owns what who's the landlord around here
someone needs to fix that toilet yeah
who's vacuuming who's putting the dishes
up I mean it's just an absolute
relationship and financial Nightmare and
I get the heart behind it Alejandro
life's expensive yeah you choose to live
in a high cost of living area and it
comes to the territory rent goes up and
you go hey on paper this is going to be
way better for all of us what's really
going to happen is it's going to destroy
the relationship with your brother and
you're probably going to end up single
within six months
yeah those are the calls we get
I'm waiting we're going to get a call
this week and someone's gonna go I
bought a house with my brother and it
was a nightmare and now my girlfriend
wants to move out and break up with me
now Alejandro George is right but on the
other side of this is just patience
which isn't Fun
but you gotta wait you can't have it all
at the same time
and I think we've got a younger
generation and I'm just trying to be
really honest with you here
we want things that we just can't afford
right now and we don't want to wait so
we try to come up with a life hack and
buying the house with your brother is a
life hack that will hack your life up
what happens when you two want to get
married and now you got to move out but
he can't afford the mortgage payment
exactly yeah what happens when he wants
to move out now you're on the hook
because you co-signed
true
situations have we scared you enough
yeah you did
I don't want to be the boogeyman here
but on the other side you know I'm not a
fan of of people cohabitating together
before marriage and if you do want to
buy a house with her do it once you guys
are married
is that on the horizon for you too
uh uh it is right now it's just um like
I mentioned earlier she's not really
like the person who while he's talking
about money too much so for me is I do
see myself living with uh being with her
for a long time but I don't know really
how I'm getting mixed signals here I am
too how long you been dating this girl
uh for two years two years what are you
waiting on but you don't see a future
whether
currently because of the money values
yeah it's just the thing is
um
like I really I talked to her about
money and stuff trying to
um
getting to like the uh the steps and all
the baby steps and I'm doing it with her
but we're not sharing money because we
both um we're she's still my girlfriend
you know I don't wanna no that's smart
but is she on board with this money
direction that you want to go
not really dude you got a dumper
no I'm serious as I can be you guys have
been together for two years and you
can't get her to see this Vision I mean
what are we what are we waiting on go
there go find some gal who loves you and
who is on the same page with you
financially this will rip your marriage
apart eventually and I just don't
understand why you would stay in it
this is a pretty big deal
I know it's terrible and then I'm not
trying to be glib we just crushed
Alejandro's dreams he was excited to get
a house no we didn't Crush I I disagree
we did not crush his dreams
we saved you from nightmares there we go
I like that version listen Mary George
help me out here what does the data say
what's the number one cause of divorce I
mean money fights and money problems is
up there how can you live a life of
Harmony in marriage when you do not see
eye to eye on money you can't what
happens is they go well you keep your
stuff separate I'll keep mine separate
and we'll just split the main bills and
everything else it's my business and
your business
yeah that creates some intimacy real
quick Alejandra push back on me what's
gonna change what's gonna change to
where she all of a sudden sees the light
what needs to happen for you to go you
know what I care about you deeply you
may even love her but you got to let her
go would she go through FPU with you if
we gave you Financial Peace University
would she watch all nine videos
yes I think she'll well because I've um
I've been talking to her about it and
then she's she's like the person she's
like yeah let's do it but at the same
time she's just you know forgets about
it the week after and I'm really trying
to get her more into it I don't think
she's forgetting about it but I'll tell
you this George you're much nicer than
me I think we give them financials I
want to give love a shot Ken I do too
but but listen if she won't go through
this with you and she won't take it
seriously you gotta dump it that's a big
red flag
and Alejandro you're going to be a
homeowner but you're gonna do it the
right way we're gonna have patience out
of debt full emergency fund good down
payment save 15-year fixed rate mortgage
that we can afford then we're ready to
be homeowners
until then it's a it's a cool dream and
I want that for you but man doing it the
wrong way will cost you way more than
the patience it takes to buy a house the
right way yeah
and and for everybody out there I love
love but I can tell you I can see the
signs when it's time
to cut the bait I mean you just at some
point you got to make a decision
should you stay or should you go I'll
give her financial peace after the class
if she doesn't do it George
breaking up with her cut it out moving
hang on the line Alejandro Austin will
pick up will get you Financial Peace
University wishing you the best of luck
my friend and true love this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America this show is just
flying by today George you know the old
phrase time flies when you're having fun
brilliant yeah I'm having a good time I
am too and again here's what's Wild our
Building Wealth live tour already
halfway over it's crazy where did it go
so where does the time go where does it
go you were in Indy I was in Austin and
we got to Salt Lake coming up April 24th
Salt Lake City if you're anywhere near
there get your tickets today you don't
want to miss this it's going to be Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Jade uh Jade warshaw
and yours truly will be there walk you
through how to save money and build
wealth like a pro yes even in this
economy and you're gonna get the proven
plan that we swear by you're gonna walk
out confident that you can win with
money and change your family tree this
stuff works we see it time and time
again always inspired by the stories we
hear from baby steps millionaires at
these events and then Ken you're going
to be in Anaheim California on May 2nd
yes with John deloney and Jade warshan
Dave Ramsey yeah gonna be fun out there
round out the spring tour in the Los
Angeles area I always love going to
Anaheim lovely Place wonderful I'm gonna
miss it we could have gone to Disney
together if I was there that's a shame
maybe we can change the lineup around a
little bit because can you see you and I
will switch to the park with our Mickey
ears on matching yeah I'm down yeah I
don't know well hey if you you can't see
that but you might see Ken in Anaheim
you'll see me in Salt Lake City tickets
are just 49 bucks and they're going fast
all of these events have been selling
out go to ramsesolutions.com events and
get yours today I love it all right the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Levi is joining
us now in Fort Worth Texas Levi how can
we help
yeah I guess thankful for having me on
um so my question is really um around
that kind of a unique situation
um I'm in the process of selling a
business that I started about eight
years ago and
um I'm going to be receiving a
substantially amount from that
transaction in the tune of about nine
million dollars oh yeah dude what kind
of business is this WOW uh it's a health
core Healthcare diagnostic service that
I started back in my early 20s actually
36 years old congratulations way to go
yeah thanks guys appreciate it
um and where I'm at right now with that
situation is looking at what my current
liabilities are and I've got about a
little over 1.2 in current debt
and the question resolves around I'm
getting some advice on not paying that
debt off and using that liquidity to go
towards more and try to create
additional income especially because
where the interest rates are so my
question is really around should I just
you know wipe that debt completely out
and start from scram you know from
Square zero if you will and continue
because I still have quite a bit of
liquidity left over and invest from
there or should I stick with that advice
to keep that debt and continue to pour
that cash into other things that can
ultimately make me make more money down
the road all right before we weigh in
George I've got to ask
Levi what were you thinking before you
got this advice and then what do you
want to do
what I was thinking before the advice
was to pay off the debt 100 uh just
because of all the payments that are
lingering you know yes they're you know
three of them are investment type deals
right but it's just a lingering fact and
yes and you've done good bigger and
bigger and bigger you did good Levi and
you're in a situation to get out of all
that debt and still have a lot of money
to invest so I don't know who's given
you the advice it's terrible advice
and you know what it's also Cavalier
which bothers me more than terrible
George Cavalier it's uh yeah well my
point is it's it's it's like it's so
glib
I mean I'm probably gonna offend
somebody whoever it is and I don't wanna
I don't hurt their feelings or who knows
but listen
they're giving you advice
about your money
like they're the ones it's so to me it's
what I mean by Cavaliers is Hey listen
why would you pay it off uh just do this
people get Starry Eyed you're not
carrying the debt exactly you're not
feeling what Levi's feeling I agree this
is my ticket and this gives me so much
freedom and if I don't have debt it
gives me more options it's that simple
Levi it's your life
so let's say you followed our advice
Levi you have 9 million net from this
deal you pay off 1.2 leaves you with 7.8
correct
probably 9 million gross so you know we
call it after taxes so yeah yeah exactly
so we're talking six and a half call it
maybe seven okay and then paying this
off so you know still looking at it yeah
we're still talking about Five Points
yeah exactly okay so let's say you you
paid off the debt you had 5.8 million
left do you need any of this money are
you in a good spot financially yourself
yeah absolutely I mean with that you
know current that you know that asset
value would be at about 2.1 million I
owe 1.2 on it so there's an asset value
there of about 2.1 million okay for
liquidity I'm sitting on about 440k good
gracious you're a crushing and are you
continuing to work for this company
after you sell it for a season I yeah
I've signed on to for a two-year
commitment how much are you going to
make salary quarter Mill bro
dude Levi this is a no lose situation I
would just pay off the debt I mean you
could invest I just did some napkin math
for you 5.8 million you invest that and
five years later it's already over 9
million
five years from now you're 41 years old
and that money has made you you know
three four million dollars
okay that doesn't even count what you're
gonna make as you go to the next chapter
I think you probably already got some
ideas what the next chapter looks like
after your two years give up 100 dude
come on man I'm inspired first of all
you know what Levi you were right George
and I are just all we're doing is
backing you up if you were right your
instincts were right but can I just tell
you I I I I'm guessing that the person
who gave you this advice is pretty
influential in your life am I right
it's a wealth management team actually
and it's a it's an exit strategy for for
how this is supposed to go and then now
what does a wealth management team stand
to gain from you investing instead of
paying off debt well a whole lot they
gain yeah see absolutely so I always
question the motives of the person we
got nothing to gain here Levi we're not
getting the dime for this not a dime
yeah not a dime but you can be
outrageously generous we'll give you
Ken's venmo after this that's right or
you know stop by Nashville and uh you
can take George and I out for a bourbon
you know who knows I mean if Dave Ramsey
was sitting here himself the man runs
this business debt free we just finished
a Event Center up the hill here millions
and millions of dollars all in cash and
the man sleeps better at night when he
doesn't owe anyone anything and you have
the ability to do that you have no
reason to ever take on debt ever again
yeah it's a no-brainer Levi you knew it
and we know it and those guys have a
they've got an ulterior motive run from
those motives run
find someone who cares more about your
financial future than their pocket and
by the way don't continue the
conversation it's done because those
guys don't keep trying to give you
another angle they sniff a guy who just
sold a company for nine mil I mean
goodness gracious they're coming for you
well that's all I'd get good people in
your corner like getting that it feels
like from all lands attorneys trying to
draft like getting these outrageous you
know amounts on these it's just
it let it be awkward because it ought to
feel awkward to you that they're just
grabbing at you and trying to get their
Hooks In You for their gain that is just
nasty ugly stuff and you ought to run
from it don't even listen to it anymore
you got it I was given some bad advice
at the beginning I guess I was told of
one thing that uh rich people have
attorneys so suck it up and pay the
bills for them and and now I'm kind of
that's quite the selling everyone going
against my gut yeah so stupid now it's
good to have an attorney in your corner
but not with that sales pitch no and so
you find one on your own volition find a
good tax Pro find a good attorney find a
good insurance Pro good real estate Pro
and a good financial advisor who has
your best interest at heart and we've
got lots of these at ramseysolutions.com
and these guys all have the heart of a
teacher and they want to help you they
want to see you in but man be careful
about who comes round on the corner now
that they smell old money Levi I tell
you what Levi you're going to be really
rich so that's going to give you the
power to
share with them two of my favorite words
pound sand I thought it was going to be
kick rocks I could go either way kick
rocks pound sand you know tell them just
you know or as George likes to say in
his did she have a Jersey accent don't
you have a little fun yeah
that's what you were digging for get out
of here that's what I was like see you
do it better than I do hey I'm from
Boston so I'm closer give me a Boston
get out of here get out of here there it
is see that's what Levi there's your new
phrase Levi what an inspiration yeah how
about this guy this is what are we doing
out here Ken I don't know I gotta I
gotta start a Healthcare Company
apparently that's the last thing you
should do stick to what you know that's
good advice for the work guy it's pretty
good George thank you I have to think I
learned from my friends
all right George and I are going to come
up with a new scheme a new company to
launch over the break we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
thrilled to have you with us I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me this
shower and in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions I see a lovely couple over
there on the debt free stage Ben and
Mary are with us hello Hi how are you
guys doing oh we're having a blast uh so
are you here to do a debt-free screen
I had a feeling all right love it very
good where do you guys live Michigan
Michigan all right and uh tell us the
story how much debt did you pay off well
we paid off just about 67 000 altogether
but uh we decided to take out student
loans out of our Lives 63
000. okay very good how long did that
take so is it 63 or 67 63 student loans
and then uh 4 000 we've systematically
started our house yep cool okay great so
uh the debt total 63. I got that right
yes okay and how long did it take you to
pay that off
um about a year and a half okay good
good and uh what was the range of income
uh right at a hundred thousand okay and
what do you guys do
I work as a patient account
representative for an outpatient billing
facility okay and I'm a teacher oh good
very nice and so you guys stayed at 100
through the whole journey yes okay
gotcha all right very good okay so
um this was the student loans we know
that so what happened a year and a half
ago where you guys said all right it's
time we got to get rid of this well we
were getting married and I brought the
debt into the relationship and
we just knew that it was something we
wanted to get out of our lives and so we
stuck to it and we got it done wow how
long have you guys been married for
almost two years oh so as soon as you
guys got married yes when we got back
from the honeymoon we wrote a check to
get her um Perkins loans out and that
was about two thousand and then uh
continued on after that wow so Ben did
you come into the marriage with any debt
no I was yeah I was already on step six
and I was paying off the house so I want
to get your perspective because this is
an interesting yeah you know side from
your angle going you coming to the mayor
hey I was debt free until you showed up
that's a lot of attitudes yeah what was
your attitude when you knew about the
death yeah our early dates were just
walks
um and we'd start talking about you know
finances and I said well do you have any
debt and she said yeah about you know
she wasn't quite sure yeah I came hard
yeah yeah yeah so you know as we
continue our relationship we got on the
right page and um
but yeah it was definitely it was tough
for me because I was investing I was
paying off debt or I was paying off the
house
um saving for the future and then I had
to put all that aside and just put
investing aside and but she was worth it
you went hey I'm happy to take a step
backwards if it means being with you for
the rest of my life well yeah you were
you were in because if I hear the story
right if I'm paying attention maybe I
wasn't you came in
and said to Ben all right uh let's get
rid of this well yes because morally I
felt like since I took the debt it was
my responsibility to pay back so Ben you
didn't have to really convince her of
anything you just went all right I'm
going to marry this guy I want to
support you in this and we're going to
do this together yes yes definitely for
you yeah that was um the whole student
loan thing was it was tough especially
we were right about ten thousand dollars
when the whole who we're gonna pay off
your loan so oh my goodness
yeah yeah so uh it was funny because I
said well sweetheart we could you know
just see what happens and save the ten
thousand and just put in a savings
account and
and you said no you're so close let's
keep going aren't you glad you did yes I
wanted to be able to say that we did it
yeah
so so what did you guys do what was the
strategy how'd you guys buckle down
together and knock this out well from my
perspective it was all the mindset
um I mean my husband's pragmatic he
would say it's the budgeting and making
sure you're on the same page with how
you use your money and how you save your
money
and from my perspective it was more or
less just giving yourself the confidence
to do it making sure that you are
willing to sacrifice and
um
I it really didn't take much so yeah and
um you know God's good so you know
tithing is huge tithing is the first
thing that we do yeah every every month
and we we found out that you know as
long as we were good stewards God always
gave us opportunities to work so then
you know income always was never a was
never an issue all right so no major
like sacrifices no rice and beans beans
and rice because you were in good shape
yeah well well I would say rice and
beans actually because my students you
know would always say Mr Bishop you
always eat the same thing every day
I mean it was usually
um I'm a Hunter so I get you know
venison
um and it's always a venison a um kills
and drags at home
I have three I have three in the freezer
right now anyway but uh it's I can't I
get like cold oven roasted turkey a
little plastic container this guy's
going out and shooting an animal
that's one way to you know sacrifice and
budget on the journey though yes I
haven't heard that one come up Ken how
did you guys save money well I ate a lot
of venison there it is yes yes and just
being and being content yeah you know
with just each other you know our one
year anniversary we went camping you
know and when you said your dates were
going on walks which I think is very
romantic and budget friendly yeah there
you go you just gotta have a good pair
of shoes that's right yeah absolutely
all right so who are you oh go ahead
Jordan I was gonna ask about the
cheerleaders was this is just you two or
were there other people involved
cheering you on
um well I would say that within my
immediate family I'm one of the first to
really buckle down and pay off my debt
because my family
I was raised in an environment of
scarcity and so debt was normal
and we all anticipated we would be
paying debt off until we died so
it was pretty emotional to be one of the
first to say I paid off sixty thousand
dollars and I would say that
you know I I feel like I did a good
thing you did how did your family react
when you told him this I think they were
a little shocked yes yeah did they get
caught on yeah actually I have a couple
of siblings that are are actually
starting the Dave Ramsey process also oh
that's incredible well you change your
family tree and you inspired family
along the way I love that so you talked
about mindset uh Mary that was your
answer so the question we usually ask is
what's the key if people are listening
in right now so Ben I'll give you a
chance uh your wife predicted what you
would say is it gonna be what you're
saying yes yeah yeah it's it's sticking
to the budget well and it's and it's
getting on a budget that we both agree
with yeah did you guys do that pretty
easily get on the same page as far as
the budget or you have to kind of figure
it out for a while well when we were
dating Ben was very transparent about
how he budgeted and how he was saved and
the money he saved for the month of he
used for the month for the next month
and so it really fell into place I I
didn't have any qualms about him being
The Guiding factor in our financial life
at all I love that I would point out
George that uh Mary just dropped a great
word she's the wife teacher you don't
hear qualms very often folks uh
Americans need would do well to put pick
that word up and drop it in uh in fact a
little bonus here one time this week for
those that are listening watching drop
qualms in this week and uh watch the
business I'd be impressed it's a very
good word I wish I had used it I wish I
said did you have any qualms but you
beat me to it no that's really what it
what a sharp really fun what do you
teach before we do the screen what do
you teach us history oh your favorite
time period yes what would you say
what's your favorite period uh oh man
I don't think I have one
um really I just yeah I love the whole
thing the whole the whole thing just the
whole thing George are we talking BC no
no no you you history goes way back yes
primarily U.S history yeah I'd say I'd
say 20th century but there you go all
right we got an answer out of it all
right you guys ready to do this before
we do this get ready to get warmed up
we've got two things for we've got Dave
Ramsey's Total Money Makeover is a gift
to you to give to somebody else and then
uh baby steps millionaire Dave's latest
book which is really your journey you
guys are on your way and it's so very
exciting to see that'll be another
teacher oh yeah in the ranks of a baby
and we've got a Financial Peace
University thank you for reminding me of
that maybe you can kick off for your
family's journey to help them along the
way there you go I hope so all right
well there it is all right let's do this
we've got Ben and Mary they paid off six
or three thousand dollars in a year and
a half making a hundred thousand dollars
they hail from the great state of
Michigan Ben and Mary take it away let's
hear your debt free screen three two
yes they
are
to see it I'm sure
three careers for millionaires that's
exactly right it's fun to see you know
what's great too as a young couple I
mean their whole life ahead of them
they've still got you know joy and hope
and energy it's a beautiful thing
I love how you drop the energy in there
I mean this they've got it I really do
well that comes from freedom and hope
about their future a true Vision great
stuff thanks Ben and Mary for sharing
your story don't move more of your calls
coming up right here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back America you're listening to
the Ramsey show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by
George Campbell we're here for you this
hour our scripture today is Proverbs 18
22 he who finds a wife finds a good
thing and obtains favor from the Lord
amen you know this is true in both of
our cases as a matter of fact we were
walking out of church yesterday James
and who do I see in front of us George
and Whitney the camels the camels were
there and we stopped and our wives were
talking and at that point we both looked
at each other and we knew what we were
thinking we knew we jackpot hit the
jackpot with Whitney and Stacy two great
women sweet uh our quote comes from Mark
Twain
uh by the way bonus points do you know
his real life name I don't have it
memorized Samuel Clemens that's it I
just watched The Mark Twain Prize yeah
the Mark Twain for Adam Sandler last
night yeah oh two-hour special oh I love
me some sailor that's fantastic rise for
American humor oh comedy very nice back
to the quote Mark Twain otherwise known
as Samuel Clemens this is in honor of
Ben our debt-free screamer who's a
history guy he's a history teacher I
fell ahead to throw it out there uh
here's the quote we'll never get there
folks here it is what would men be
without women
scarce sir
Mighty that's good for some of you it'll
hit you at 11 o'clock tonight Slow Burn
on that one we should we we should talk
like that I love Mark Twain quotes I
can't know but I just like when somebody
asks a question you know if somebody
says George uh what do I do uh with all
my credit card debt versus my student
loans and you should say use the debt
snowball sir like that would be really
funny if we went back to the pages let's
try it on our next call let's see
um okay now is this angel or on hell
Angel ah see I was trying to guess these
names Angels on the line in McAllen
Texas Angel how can we help
hey how's it going guys how you all
doing we're having a blast how can we
help
um uh my question was the uh mortgage
question actually
um back in uh into uh 2021
um I got a I got my first home um I'm 33
years old
and at the time I had saved up to 200
um you know and savings just saved and
uh the mortgage is two 290 000 so I was
pretty I was ready for it
um and I went in kind of aggressively on
it and I went in uh I put in a hundred
thousand
uh down
so and then uh since then I've just been
going month to month
um and now I got I'm around 185 a little
under 26 left on it
um and I've since then I've built myself
back up my savings back up to 200 000.
whoa so I'm kind of I'm kind of yeah I'm
kind of tempted you know to uh
just go on and pay it off and I'll be
left to those 15 and then build back up
on those 15 and build myself back up you
know after just going all in and paying
it off or is that like way too much you
know maybe give another just a hundred
thousand or well do you have any other
day I just kind of sit back and uh no uh
other than that mortgage I'm pretty much
that three so you'd have 15 000 to your
name how many uh months of an emergency
fund would that be for you for expenses
that fifteen thousand yeah uh it could
be up on three to six if it's at least
three months I'm paying off that
mortgage today get the final payoff
statement yeah get that thing done it is
for sure uh three yeah especially with
your ability to save you are you are
like a super saver yeah dude you're
gonna save that back up in no time but
absolutely
if you had if you had 15 grand I mean
would you go into debt 200 000 to do
this right now if you were completely
debt free
yeah I mean I'd be difficult 15 and
still be a building back up on it this
year what's your income
uh my income is between uh it varies
because I work in the oil and gas
industry so worst case uh I work these
seasonal contract jobs so you know worst
case out uh like 80 in the 80s and if I
have a really good one like I have these
last couple years uh it'll be a hundred
uh pay off the house today my man I'm so
happy for you I don't know why we're
just talking let's I mean you should
hang up on us now and call the mortgage
company just do it why are the money
today and then just build back up yes
you're a savings machine
when next month hits with no mortgage
payment you are going to be over the
moon yes I'll save even quicker and then
do it no more talking about it I'm
putting you on hold you're done with
Angel we're done he knows what to do you
are amazing sir easiest call we've taken
see what I just did there
amazing sir see hey you got to work that
in I don't know where the guttural sir I
think it's unnecessary yeah yeah I agree
all right let's go to Patrick in Tulsa
Oklahoma Patrick how can we help yes sir
thank you so much for taking my call and
thank you so much for the ministry that
you all provide thank you thank you sir
it's an honor
the question that I have for you is this
I am 62 years old and warrant is 60.
I've had been with my journey for uh 37
years my Milwaukee married for almost 43
years our total household income is
approximately uh ninety five thousand
dollars when I'm starting this journey
many years ago 2009 I had approximately
425 000 a bit my house has paid for
colleges a long time ago Karen's float
my daughter's College carouslogged their
weddings as well I have a little bit of
consumer with that if you want to call
sixty thousand dollars a little I have
sixty thousand dollars Consumer Debt yet
still with me then that is it my future
business is uh uh I was 17 000 on that
which is part of the 60 as well uh what
I want to do when I do finally retry
from that is I want to raise cattle I've
got approximately uh 140 Acres out there
and uh so my question is this do I go
ahead and start investing now and since
the house is paid for in college all
those other baby steps are done except
for the 60 000 the Consumer Debt and
kind of consider that my household my
house to pay it on it or do I go ahead
and ride this thing all the way up and
knock out the Consumer Debt then start
paying it the way that I figure it'll be
probably three years which that's only
65 years of age by the time everything
is completely done
I am paying off the debt I wouldn't
invest a dime until you got all that
Consumer Debt paid off
okay because truthfully right now
compound interest is not going to be
your ticket to a great retirement
is starting investing in your 60s what
is going to be helpful is lowering all
of your expenses and having no debt
payments whatsoever including a mortgage
payment and then just saving up
ferociously once all that consumer debts
paid off
okay I've already got a little bit in my
uh 401 and my Roth uh a little over a
hundred thousand in that plus I have a
pension plan as well with the company
that I've been with of approximately 26
years uh to add on top of that but I
don't know how to calculate my pension
and my in my retirement and my total net
value net worth on that because it will
not let me uh roll it to a 401k that
will not let me do any of that stuff I
wouldn't count the pension in the net
worth but right now what you're looking
at is how do we limit our expenses and
cover everything on a budget with
whatever retirement looks like with the
pension with the 401K but again you'll
have no payments by then and you may
need to work a little bit longer are you
guys in good health can you work one you
know from 65 to 68 69 oh yeah yes yes
very easy very easy yes I have no
reading since none of that stuff yeah
good shape okay you can still retire
with dignity but I would not try to do a
bunch of things at once investing a
little bit trying to pay off the debt a
little bit this interest is going to
hurt your retirement more than not
investing right now yeah and we only got
about a minute but what kind of risk is
involved with the cattle Venture because
that worries me a little bit that's an
expensive business
well uh that's what I've done uh it's
kind of like on the side there's a kid
growing up um I don't consider it like a
big risk owner okay I mean you know you
always have your expenses like when here
in Oklahoma the drought at the feed and
the hay goes up but what I do to help uh
pay for that I'll sell off one or two of
those that'll Carry Me Through the
winter have more babies that'll for next
year and go forth like that okay all
right we'll just do it all with cash
okay and don't put your retirement at
risk for this stream yeah I I I I I I I
think there's so much going on there oh
yeah I'm laying it out it's like simple
as the play going forward and great
advice there you're absolutely right for
somebody that age
the compound interest is you're just not
gonna you don't have 20 years to let
that that's the way to go yeah
minimizing expenses wow really good
advice George Campbell always fun my
friend to be with you by the way when
you uh retire will you have a camel farm
uh you know I'm not much of a farmer
maybe a horse though that might might be
fun really or not a camel ah camels are
dirty well I'm really trying they're
dirty animal trying hard hey always fun
to be with my friend you too man great
advice today I want to thank James and
the crew for keeping us on the air and
to you America thank you for listening
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]